Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be my avatar the way of
water video for the ending of the movie how
they're setting up the sequels of the big teasers in
the plot threads that they're going to resolve
in the rest of the sequels there were a lot of
moments in the movie that seemingly went nowhere
but it's all meant to be set up for the sequels
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get the videos and I'll separate
this between the different arcs like you have
quairtch's arc you have what's going on with
Jake Sully's family then you have what's going
on with Kiri herself careful for spoilers for
the movie if you haven't seen it yet because
we'll be talking about everything that happens
at the end but starting with courage's Arc so
during the movie we find out that courage backed
up his Consciousness and back on Earth they had
been growing him and most of his hardcore Squad
mates Avatar bodies at the beginning of the movie
they're meant to be like the best of the worst of
the humans and they very clearly set up a Darth
Vader style Redemption Arc for courage through
the rest of the movies however many sequels they
wind up doing now they said that they were going
to do five movies but James Cameron's like well
we could end it with three movies and it would
still be a satisfying ending it just depends on
how much money this second movie winds up earning
the new avatar version of Courage starts out with
all of the original courses memories hating Jake
Sully wanting revenge and Full Tilt working for
Earth's new general add more on Pandora played
by Edie Falco she's kind of like the new version
of courage in this movie she explains that
her Mission since the end of the last movie
has been to permanently colonize Pandora for the
survivors of Earth like Earth is basically making
Pandora its new home because the Earth is dying
as a planet and Humanity has to move somewhere
else or else they'll die too Earth still wants
unobtainium it's still very valuable but also
since the events of the first movie scientists on
earth have discovered a special fluid secreted by
the brains of the tulkoon whale species which
completely stopped the aging process in humans
a small vial is worth like 80 million dollars and
it's now the most important most valuable resource
humans are harvesting on the planet like they
barely even mentioned unobtaining like this is
the reason we're here now this special fluid just
also remember that most of the survivors of Earth
are moving to Pandora eventually like that's
way off in the future the main reason courage
is after Jake Sully in the first part of the
movie like the first half is because he was
leading a raiding party hurting all the generals
colonization efforts and he wanted to stop that
eventually though while this is happening he finds
that Jake Sully has been raising his own human son
calling him spider a boy the original version
of Courage had sired with one of the other human
women on the planet before his death his birth
name was Miles he's named after corks himself
like he gave him his own name his full name
was Miles court so he's like miles quartitch jr
I am your father and thus begins courage's Darth
Vader Arc where Court will probably go from not
caring about the boy because he's not even the
same courage like he acknowledges that during
the film he's fundamentally a different person
than the original version he eventually begins to
care about the boys if he were his son and slowly
starts to show signs that spider has helped him
to appreciate Pandora the planet more and more
until the end of the movie where spider saves
his life James Cameron already said the courts
will be one of the main antagonists through all
the sequels however many they wind up making
but here's where we get to the Darth Vader Arc
eventually courts will probably grow to appreciate
Pandora so much that he gets a much longer version
of the arc that Jake Sully got in the first movie
where he starts out not caring about anything on
Pandora until he eventually sympathizes with
the locals and helps them stop the humans from
destroying the planet completely depending on how
many sequels they wind up making they'll speed
that arc up like if they end it with the third
movie then he'll probably sacrifice himself to
save Pandora and his son in the third movie like
Darth Vader redeeming himself by trying to kill
the emperor in Return of the Jedi now moving to
Jake Sully's Arc so during Jake Sully's ending he
decides that he's done running the new water tribe
that they joined the Metkayina is their permanent
home now and they're going to continue to defend
it aggressively in the third movie beyond that
we'll see James Cameron originally teased we'd
see different environments on Pandora through the
different sequels so if they do all the sequels
like four and five as well we'll probably visit
very different parts of Pandora but if they only
wind up doing the third movie then we'll probably
just stay in this water-based environment the
producer of the movie also teased that James
Cameron wasn't going to take the movies back to
planet Earth because for a little while he also
Teasley might see what's happening on Earth while
this is all going on through the sequels now it
sounds like that's not the case the other major
teaser is for Sigourney Weaver's character Kiri
she has a special connection with Eywa the life
force of the planet itself that's part of every
living thing on the planet they're setting her up
to be the Anakin Skywalker of the series to make
a Star Wars metaphor the Immaculate Conception
the special child created by Eywa itself during
the flashbacks we learned that Grace Augustine
Sigourney Weaver's human character from the first
movie discovered the life force of AWA existed
in all living things on the planet the navi the
animals the plant life the ocean life everything
is sort of like her character discovered the
Avatar movie version of midichlorians on Pandora
it's Consciousness so to speak eventually her
Avatar body gives birth it's an Immaculate
Conception there's meant to be no father and the
human created avatars weren't even supposed to do
that like that was never part of the engineering
plan when they designed them throughout the movie
Kiri keeps talking about how she is different
from all the other Navi even like Jake Sully's
human created Avatar she can literally hear the
heartbeat of eywa itself they show a couple scenes
where you see the pulsing motion of the plant life
around her she listens to the planet's heartbeat
she's able to control all types of biological life
on eywa just like in the Star Wars Universe Force
users use the force to do things the difference
in avatar The Way of water is that James Cameron
is making more of a literal connection between
Kiri in the life force of the planet saying that
she's essentially influencing the avatar version
of midichlorians that exists in all living things
on the planet to do whatever she wants them to
do so she uses the ability to trap the humans
using the underwater plants in the final fight
she tells the small sea creatures to light the
way to her family who's trapped inside the human
sunken ship they imply that she can use it to
do bigger things too like she's just starting
out just slowly figuring out how it works that'll
continue through the sequels as she learns to use
the Ability become more and more powerful earlier
in the movie when she directly connects with eywa
using that underwater version of the spirit tree
it's meant to be like a direct connect terminal
to the consciousness of the planet the reason why
she has a seizure and almost dies is because it's
just too much information too much power all at
once before she's figured out how to use it when
she's doing that she's basically plugging herself
in feeling the entire planet all at the same time
it'd be like Anakin Skywalker trying to become
a Force ghost when he was like eight years old
it was squish's mind just accessing way too much
power way too much life force across the Galaxy
all at the same time all the sequel movies are
meant to continue following Jake Sully's family
and the kids will become much more important to
the sequels like we'll probably jump forward in
time a little bit if they wind up doing all the
sequels so the kids will be much older by the
final film I think they're just setting up the
Kiri is going to go full Anakin Skywalker child
of the Pandora Force become way more powerful
and use that to defeat the worst of the humans
with everyone else in quartitch's help remember
quaritch is on the Darth Vader Arc gonna wind up
helping Jake Sully's family but also talking about
what's happening back on Earth with the humans
because Earth is in the middle of dying because
Pandora has all these resources that can help
heal the earth I think they'll eventually come to
a compromise where Kiri the other survivors and
whatever the final film winds up being help heal
the Earth literally using all these new powers
and the new resources from Pandora coming to a
compromise so that the humans will eventually
stop trying to destroy Pandora and terraform it
into something that they want they'll just leave
it alone one of the big things with James Cameron
is that he's this big ocean conservationist like
that's a big part of his message you see a
lot of those promos on the Avatar YouTube
channel expanding world of Avatar allows us to
appreciate the beauty of our biomes here on Earth
let's cover 70 percent of the
diversity of laforce and shaping the way we live
without significant change more than half of the
world's marine species may face Extinction
before the end of the century they spent a
lot of time talking about the real world impact
that we as people in real life have on Earth's
oceans so I think a big part of this is teasing
that the humans on Earth in the world of Avatar
right now are really terrible like it's a bunch of
rich people basically just strip mining the Earth
for its resources and they're now trying to do it
to Pandora with a special fluid so like the real
Ultimate villain of the Avatar movies are like
super old super rich people that just want this
resource to stop themselves from aging eventually
I think the idea is that Kiri the other survivors
even courage will wind up defeating those people
in like all the rest of the regular people on
Earth will grow to respect the Earth much more
because of what Kiri winds up doing and it'll be
like a new beginning for Humanity but on planet
Earth like I don't think that James Cameron is
that cynical he's not going to kill the Earth
literally during the world of the Avatar movies
but I do hope that we actually do see a little
bit of what's actually happening back on Earth
I'm not expecting a ton of that during the third
movie I think that they wind up doing the fourth
and the fifth movies then we'll see more about
what's happening with Earth he did say that most
of the third movie was filmed while they were
filming the second movie and it's mostly done
but it's like a nine hour movie right now and he
still has to cut it down there's still a bunch
more footage they actually have to shoot for it
currently their plan is to release Avatar 3 in
2024 around the same time that the second movie
came out in December we probably won't find out
whether or not they're going to do the fourth
or the fifth movie to like well into next year
because if you remember the original Avatar movie
made over like two billion dollars but it got a
really slow start like it didn't start earning
billions of dollars until many many months after
been 13 years it still feels like this movie
is going to do gangbusters I feel like the new
studio which is now Disney because they own Fox
and technically Avatar is a fox franchise the
studio will put some pressure on him to just like
cut the run time down to like two and a half two
hours 45 minutes like okay we'll let you do all
your sequels just please just cut the movie down
just like a little bit we could always do like a
mini series elongated director's version on Disney
Plus in the far future he also joked about that
too about wanting to release like a broken up six
part or eight part mini-series version that's
much longer on Disney Plus or like a streaming
platform like here's the condensed three hour plus
theatrical version but also here's the streaming
version that's like twice as long everyone
posts all your predictions for the sequels
in the comments and if you have any big questions
about any of the big storylines or the big teasers
that they set up for Avatar 3 or even the further
off sequels just write them in the comments below
there's a bunch of big stuff coming up we're gonna
get some more Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
trailer videos really soon because that movie
is coming out in February so while you wait for
everything everyone click here for that brand
new Henry Cavill Warhammer trailer video Big W
for Henry Cavill and click here to learn about
the Game of Thrones Jon Snow sequel from Kit
Harington thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!